Up until now, we have
analyzed the motion of objects
that we treated as so-called
point masses, where literally
all of the mass of
the object was treated
as lying at a single point.
This is obviously an
unrealistic idealization.
Real objects have
spatial extent and come
in various sizes and
shapes, some regular
and some highly irregular.
The mass distribution within
these extended objects
might be smooth and uniform or
highly non-uniform and lumpy.
Moreover, sometimes, we will
be interested in simultaneously
analyzing a large system
of particles or objects.
To deal properly
with such situations,
it is necessary to introduce
a new physical quantity called
the momentum, which is a vector
that we traditionally denote
with the symbol P. For
a single point mass,
the momentum is the product
of the mass and the velocity
vector.
The form of Newton's second
law that we have used so far,
F equals ma, is actually only
true for the special case
of a point mass.
The more general form of
the Newton's Second Law
is that F equals dp/dt,
that is that the force is
equal to the time derivative
of the momentum vector.
This is applicable to
either a single particle
or to a system of particles.
This more general
form provides us
the way to address
extended objects
or multi-particle systems.
We will once again appeal
to a calculus-like argument,
breaking down an
extended distribution
into a large number
of small elements,
treating each element
separately, and then summing
the results.
As part of this process, we
will introduce the concept
of the center of mass, a sort of
mass weighted average position
for an extended
object or system.
Momentum is also the first
of several special measurable
quantities that we will discuss
that obey special powerful
rules called conservation laws.
The other two quantities are
energy and angular momentum.
Conservation laws are principles
to provide that the given
measurable quantity remains
unchanged during the evolution
of a system with time as long
as certain requirements are
met, essentially the requirement
that a system remains isolated.
With this restriction in
place, the possible evolution
of motion of a particle
or system of particles
is greatly restricted,
simplifying its calculation.
We will see how this can
be used to our advantage
in understanding
what will happen.